you probably fell asleep on your
computer and now we move from the
flatulent prepubescent superheroes of
south park to the snowy post pandemic
streets of New York in Tom Clancy's the
division thanks to all of you out there
the division broke records when it
launched earlier this year and today
more than 10 million of you have spent
up to three hours a day hitting a steady
supply of high-value targets and trying
to get your hands on the best loot in
the dark zone well here to tell us more
about what's new in the division ladies
and gentlemen please welcome Julian
Garrity creative director from massive
entertainment
alright thank you and thank you for
wearing those shoes I'd like to make I'm
not actually that's sure no no you're
actually taller than me about these
shoes on I'm sorry I'll go with a hey
and thanks to all the division players
out there who are so passionate about
our game yeah it's a cool cool last game
and you guys have been adding all kinds
of new stuff to the game since it
debuted we heard just a little while ago
about the underground so you want to
tell us more about what's going on with
absolutely so in underground you and
your team will be fighting against a
dangerous threat hidden beneath the
streets of New York City and every time
you play the challenge is unique that
means endless replayability and even
better rewards the further you go okay
so I mean one of the cool thing about
this game is it is open world it is so
robust and you're making it more robust
all the time so are you gonna tell us
when we're going to get this new content
or do I just have to start taking bets I
know I'm big animal so pushy yes I agree
underground will be out jun 28th on xbox
one and pc and august second on ps4 and
this is just one of the updates will be
releasing this year because for the
division team this is a long-term
commitment we love this world you love
this world we're going to keep on making
it better for you that's awesome I mean
you know I've been in love with this
game since you guys first debuted at one
of the shows that I have said I'm really
really excited about it cool and that's
not the only thing we're going to tell
you about today we've got a little
surprise for you to celebrate ubisoft's
30th birthday we're giving our fans
three exclusive outfits to using game
Ghost Recon rainbow six and splints
you get an outfit you get an outfit Chad
you get the three outfits good for you
Jeff so if you're a member of Ubisoft
club all of these outfits will be three
for you with the release of underground
it's like smashing two or three or four
games together that you love tell the
others I I know I have a lot of feeling
they let us do this okay look over it
well I'm super stoked about running
around manhattan in trifocal goggles
without getting arrested like I
typically do so we've got underground
we've got dope new outfits more we've
got one more expansion to talk to you
about today in it you'll struggle to
find me get supplies in New York and
fight to survive in some of the most
brutal weather conditions imaginable
it's a completely new way of playing the
game and you'll be able to play it very
soon even sooner if you're on xbox one
or pc ladies and gentlemen this is
survival yeah
blizzard was getting worse but we had to
investigate the rumors of a cure
the storm took everything
no food no water temperature dropping
over here we are not alone out here come
on this yeah yeah in this world it's
hunter against Bray
we
he's out better
the storm doesn't care if you live
or die
you eating
but some of us will survive
you